so I'm finally like getting to do some
stuff I'm going to Lowe's yelling at
people in there for telling me to social
distance from people I was in a Lowe's
two days ago and I'm wearing a mask I'm
wearing gloves I'm the only person in
they're not the only but pretty much the
only person in there with gloves and in
a mask and I'm in line they got these
little X's where they want you to stand
on as you're checking out so that you're
far enough away and I was on my ex I'm
the only person in line including the
cashier with gloves and a mask I'm on my
ex the lady comes the lady in front of
me is not on her ex and she's close to
me but I don't care I'm covered and the
lady comes from behind the cash register
yells at me and tells me to give this
lady her space and I said I'm standing
on the effing ass but I didn't say
effing I was wondering what you actually
said that I let him have it in there I
was like I'm the only person in here
that seems to even care about this thing
and you're yelling at me I'm not have it
I'm not having it and then these guys
when I left out of the store they were
coming in they didn't have the mass they
didn't have gloves and they were you
know they were really trying to tough
they were trying to look at me like I'm
some kind of idiot
you know like they want to they're like
trying to make heavy eye contact with me
like they're making fun of me with their
eyes but I'm not having it I gave them a
wave with my gloved hand
yeah the gloved wow that's great yeah
I'd love for them to ask me about it why
are you wearing all that well cuz I
don't want to catch coronavirus I'm
trying to breathe around here you know
what I mean hey hot brother and sister
if you love comedy as much as we do here
at hot breath click the subscribe button
to join the hot breath averse and then
watch more videos to get even more
comedy tips